thank you
no no she doesn't no go take out you
take yourself okay no no no no no that's
not yourself no no no
um no no please leave please leave
can you just leave please
this is the problem like actually just
leave please
no take her out figure out can I just
say I don't take her get out get out
hold on don't worry about it it's just a
it's just a show it's just a show
it's just a show it's just a show I
respect you but it I just just sit down
and have a good show I don't want you to
leave no no good I don't want good right
now she's go just please be respectful
that's all she's saying
okay yeah just watch out bro watch out
bro she's a black belt in karate